[Music]
what happened in london just shattered
us
i go for evening walk my mother goes for
evening walk this could have been any
one of us
i do not wear my hijab only and
occasionally because i'm afraid someone
will target me
someone will decide wanted to kill me
our canada is a place
of racism muslims are not safe in this
country
don't tell me your thoughts are with the
muslim community
tell me what you're going to do about
racism in this country
in london ontario tonight thousands
gathered for a vigil
here to grieve for the family murdered
targeted because of their faith
and to show their support for those left
behind local faith leaders
were there and politicians from all the
federal political parties
this was about more than grief though it
was a call to action
to end islamophobia
to those who want to hide behind freedom
of expression
i ask you a simple question
what is the point of freedom of
expression
if a canadian family does not have the
freedom
to walk on a sidewalk in this country
without getting murdered
good evening and thanks for joining us
three generations of one family
are dead their relatives have asked for
privacy
though late today they did release this
photo
these are their names 46 year old solman
afsal
his 44 year old wife madiha solman
their 15 year old daughter yumna afsal
and salman's 74 year old mother whose
name has not been released
a fifth family member the couple's
nine-year-old son faiz
is in hospital with serious injuries he
lost his parents
his sister and his grandmother
thousands of people from london and
across ontario are at the vigil
there tonight a powerful sign of
solidarity and a gesture of love and
support for those left behind including
nine-year-old fayez who is now an orphan
prime minister justin trudeau calls what
happened
an act of terrorism motivated by hate
there are no words that can ease
the grief of having three generations
murdered in their neighborhood there are
no words
that can undo the pain and yes the anger
of this community there are no words
that can fix the future of that little
boy who has had his future taken away
together we will take action
together we will find our way
forward
foreign and the crowd
you know thousands and thousands donna
to the point where they're far down the
street and can't even
see the stage or any of the screens
people you know coming to show their
support today
to the muslim community this crowd is
very mixed muslims and non-muslims alike
premier doug ford is speaking now he
just called this an act of terrorism
to arousing applause before him the
national
council of canadian muslim the head of
that organization
said that we need an emergency summit
right now to address islamophobia
bilal rahel is the chairperson of this
very mosque behind me here's what he had
to say
this is our city and we're not we're not
going to let hate
scare us or intimidate us or divide us
yes we do expect from our political
leaders to take action
and yes we do expect to see
some policies in place
but we need to recognize that we belong
here
this is our city and we're not going
anywhere
thank you very much there is
collective grief in this crowd uh
there's anger there's
energy to make a difference to try to
change this conversation to that of
of hope and what a better future for
muslim kids and for kids who are
from different marginalized communities
but there's also a sense of fear donna
and i've spoken to a lot of
muslim women who are availed who say
they're still scared
because they go on that walk that that
family went on almost every day
back to you nasser at the vigil in
london tonight thank you
global nationals jeff semple is also in
london right now he's standing near the
intersection where the family was hit
by that pickup truck jeff
yeah donna it has been an absolutely
heart-wrenching day in this community
and take a look here
as we're standing at the site where the
family was killed
and this crowd has really been growing
by the minute here tonight at one point
people
were lining both sides of this street
some people climbing to lay flowers
others openly sobbing everyone here just
trying to come to terms with the horror
of what happened here on sunday night
and a warning that some of the details
in this report are difficult to hear
kosar maki and her family were driving
past this intersection at around 8 40
sunday night
they stopped at the red light and waved
at a group of pedestrians
a family of five wearing traditional
muslim dress
who were waiting to cross the street my
husband just rolled down his window and
said salaam alaikum to him
and he said salaam alaikum and he went
as soon as we turned the way we got home
minutes later we heard the ambulances
assalamu alaikum
the arabic greeting means peace be upon
you it was likely the last words
they spoke moments later police say this
pickup truck sped towards the family
jumped the curb and plowed into them
police say they were targeted
because of their islamic faith it's
scary because my husband and my children
we walk
these these these sidewalks and
and we have other families too that walk
these sidewalks and it could have been
us
that's what i keep thinking it could
have been us jen carp arrived moments
later to find bodies strewn
dozens of meters down the street none of
them were moving
except for the youngest fayez ufsell
just nine years old
he was found lying on the ground he's
crying where's my family
i want my family my leg hurts my hand
hurts we told him the
there was people helping his family and
that
you know we had he had to go to the
hospital and just i told him to
keep his head down and we were trying to
make sure he didn't see his family
it's terrible the boy remains in
hospital
and is expected to survive a family
friend says he still doesn't know that
his grandmother
his parents and his 15-year-old sister
are gone
it was a really tragic scene like even
the police officers were
in tears friends say the family arrived
from pakistan about 14 years ago and
were well known in the community
the couple salman and madiha both in
their forties
worked as a physiotherapist and an
environmental engineer
their daughter fifteen-year-old yumna
was a bright student
at this high school where flags are
flying at half mast
very shy very loving and you know she
was the kind who would look at you smile
and look away
you know that that's a beautiful smile
the community is devastated
horrified but not all are surprised
i'm afraid for my life for my daughter's
life
what do you do you go out and you know
you you know
every truck i see i look at it and i see
a white guy and i'm
i you know i they should open guns man
seriously
i need protection we came here looking
for peace i see racism every day
every freaking day
jeff the police are saying little about
the accused other than that he was
motivated by
hate he faces four charges of first
degree murder and one of attempted
murder
what more do we know yeah donna tonight
many of the details around the suspect's
life remain shrouded in mystery i spoke
to a number of his friends who live in
this community who say they are in shock
but also in disbelief they say they
never had any inkling that their friend
could allegedly be capable of carrying
out such an atrocity
i would never believe that he could have
done something like this at all
anyone else i would believe could do
this but nate not at all
yeah why do you say that it's just not
his personality
like at all like it's quite a shock
armand moridporian has known the suspect
nathaniel veltman for several years and
last saw
him just three weeks ago they worked
together in the shipping department at
this egg farm in the nearby community of
strathroy
london police visited the planet tuesday
afternoon morodporian's family is from
iran and he was raised to be a muslim
but says the suspect never appeared to
take issue with that
like he never ever thought twice about
like me and him were great friends he
helped me out a lot when i was going
through a lot of rough stuff
no one answered the door at his parents
home friends say he'd had a fight
with his family and moved out a few
years ago his grandmother passed away on
friday
moriparian says the suspect had been
arrested before for public intoxication
but otherwise was a devout christian who
mostly stayed out of trouble
quiet friendly homeschooled christian
kid literally
and that is now a question for police
investigators to answer how does a
so-called
quiet friendly christian kid become an
alleged
mass murderer we have scoured his social
media accounts online and turned up very
little the accounts
didn't have much in the way of content
at all police say he had no criminal
record
no known ties to any hate group and at
this point donna they believe
he was working alone okay jeff semple
in london ontario thanks this attack
like the mosque shooting in quebec city
is yet another sign racism and
islamophobia
exist in canada not just feelings of
hatred but for some a willingness
to act on them listen to some of the
people farah nasser has been speaking to
he said dr saab salman is no more
it's a shock to the system for empty as
khan and a reminder that muslim
canadians aren't as safe as they should
be in this country
khan can't believe one of his closest
friends salman afzal is gone
i wish you know how genuine and honest
and sincere and good
person he was the two played cricket
together he says the father was a pillar
in the community
helping new immigrants settle in london
he was the one who will buy
groceries he'll the one he will take
people for
driving tests who are new to canada but
even with a large pakistani muslim
population
some say there has always been an
underlying hidden hate here
a survey conducted by ipsos for the
national council of canadian muslims in
april of 2019
showed a quarter of canadians feel it
has become more acceptable to be
prejudiced against muslims
over the past five years if you wear
hijab or if you're wearing
i'm not wearing proper dress but
whatever then you can feel that
people have some you know they give you
a look
in 2017 a gunman stormed in a quebec
city mosque killing six men
and injuring 19 others in september of
2020
muhammad aslam zafiz was stabbed outside
the mosque where he was a caretaker
bibi zafiz is his only daughter my
condolence to you guys
i passed through the same thing that you
guys know facing
my dad got killed by a hate crime i am
so sorry
that it happened to your family that
attack has yet to be designated as a
hate crime
the last time we interviewed zafiz she
wore a hijab not anymore
i'm afraid someone will target me
someone would throw things at me and
someone will decide wanted to kill me
that could have killed my dad but for
others their resolve has been
strengthened by this senseless tragedy
i was just crying and i was worried
about her safety too
so yeah but so far people have been nice
to her so
hopefully no more hate
to carry on and
just a note dada madiha salman's sister
just spoke moments ago saying
that her sister she was the mother her
sister would want muslim women to still
wear the hijab and not to live in fear
her son who's nine years old is the only
one left who was there that day
and there has been there have been two
separate fundraisers for him that have
raised together
1.3 million dollars and that continues
to grow donna
my whole country thank you in london
thanks the perception that canada is a
welcoming tolerant place for people of
all backgrounds and faiths is one we
want to believe and in many cases it is
true
but there is a darkness lurking
anti-muslim hate and racism exists
it thrives online it is sometimes stoked
by politicians
and as eric sorensen reports there's
evidence it's growing i'm lost this
londoner doesn't even know what to say
to his son who's watching this horrible
story on the news
so he's listening to all these these new
words about hate crime
islamophobia it is a reality muslim
canadians confront and other canadians
often
ignore a level of hate increasingly
towards muslims
it is so distressing for those who
believed they were welcomed in this
country
every so often there's just it bob's his
ugly head that okay hey we're still here
you're not wanted there has been a
steady increase in police reported hate
crimes in canada from fewer than 1200 in
2013
to more than 1900 in 2019. the number of
hate crimes motivated just by religion
overall actually fell 7 in 2019
the most recent year from statistics
canada but hate crimes against the
muslim population
rose 9 percent that same year
this researcher says some hate groups
can stoke fear of muslims that can lead
to violence
and some individuals may not even join a
group individuals
consuming uh you know what they are
finding
on some of these white supremacist
islamophobic neo-nazi sites
and that is informing their own view of
the world
london like canada is home to a growing
muslim population
hate crimes here are above the national
average as they are in several major
cities
but some academics say canadians must
recognize a dark side to their image as
a welcoming country there is
a virulent strain of anti-immigrant
anti-muslim sentiment in canada and
unfortunately
not all of the political class is
willing to accept that
and deal with it accordingly advocates
say anti-muslim hatred
has to bring more than just condemnation
we don't need just to tackle white
supremacy but we also need to
you know prosecute the perpetrators but
also the people that are inciting this
hatred and this fair
you know online and elsewhere in
communities the rate of hate crimes
appears unlikely to drop
until hate itself is addressed more
directly eric sorensen global news
toronto
later in the newscast putting aside the
politics that can sometimes fuel
intolerance
and how the tourism industry is itching
for the canada-us border to reopen
the federal government is getting ready
to loosen the rules for fully vaccinated
travelers bloomberg news is reporting
changes to quarantine requirements could
happen in the coming days
as michael couture explains communities
that rely on cross-border tourism
can't wait there were tentative dates
discussed
june 21st that's when the mayor of
niagara falls says
canada could start welcoming fully
vaccinated tourists
it's based on conversations with public
safety minister bill blair
once seventy five percent of canadians
have their first dose and
twenty percent have their second and
he's told in july
another step forward the understanding
that we could have again further
loosening of the border restrictions so
that we can have more free flowing back
and forth between
canada and the united states prime
minister justin trudeau wouldn't confirm
or deny the loosening of restrictions
later this month
and on the bloomberg report that hotel
quarantine rules will be eased for fully
vaccinated travelers
trudeau says they're looking into it
easing of restrictions will be focused
on canadians who are
fully vaccinated both because that's
what the science
dictates particularly when it comes to
some of the new variants of concern like
the delta variant
medical experts agree but also note when
canada does open to tourists
we'll need a standard for what counts as
full vaccination
a phased approach using places where we
think the vaccine supply is reliable
where a fully vaccinated individual
fits the criteria where the vaccines are
similar and ones that have been approved
by the fda and help canada
that's perhaps why the government has
yet to lay out a road map for reopening
the border
still businesses say they need a plan so
they can be ready
the americans will have a very robust
summer tourism season
in canada we're likely to lose most of
it now as businesses wait for a plan to
roll out the prime minister is
encouraging people to roll
up their sleeves and get fully
vaccinated
so that borders can reopen mike lacouter
global news ottawa
putting politics aside still ahead calls
for direct action to deal with
islamophobia
you're watching global national
[Music]
political debate was set aside in the
house of commons today as party leaders
reflected on the events in london
the worst kind of politics can and does
deepen divides and fuel intolerance
as our chief political correspondent
david aiken reports today
it was the ndp leader who clearly
articulated
what needs to change ndp leader
sang was angry and i think about what
that means when people say this is not
our canada
the reality is this is our canada this
is our canada you should cut your
turbine off
singh a sikh canadian has been the
target himself
of racist and sometimes violent attacks
we don't want to be intimidated by hate
often by those who confuse him for a
muslim
he had this call to action we need to
tackle online hate
it is a real thing online hate is
radicalizing people
online hate is spreading messages that
teach people to hate
the prime minister is ready to move as
leaders
and as canadians we not only have to say
enough is enough we must take action
the prime minister noted his government
has already boosted funding for
anti-racism programs and
will provide more security
infrastructure money
for mosques and other places of worship
and he promised to do more
this is happening here in canada
and it has to stop the opposition leader
erin o'toole turned his thoughts
to the attack's lone survivor
nine-year-old
faiz upsil because there's a
nine-year-old boy lying in a hospital
bed
we have to strive to learn
and be better the canada
of his future needs to be better
than the canada of sunday evening david
a can global news
ottawa
next in their own words muslim voices
leading their community
and the country through grief
it is hard to put into words what so
many people are feeling about the muslim
family murdered in london
targeted the police say because of their
faith
knowing such hatred exists among us is
hard to reconcile
we leave you tonight with some voices
from the community
who have found words my first reaction
was to don't believe that that
it happened again we still have
uh hatred that
may that may make murder
and this is it's very very hard to to uh
to accept it's horrific
it's numbing it's painful it's
excruciating
for myself not surprising where do we go
where do muslims
go we're not safe in our places of
worship we are not safe on the streets
of canada
they were out for a walk on a sunday
night
like many of us do and they were
targeted because of their faith
today we mourn that beautiful family
when a muslim hears of a death
we say
from god we come into god we return
so let's spend a minute in silence
mourning that beautiful family
and also rededicating ourselves to
fighting racism wherever we see it